une première visite après deux ans de
travaux le 12 avril 1969 le pari fou du
dixième marque et de breteuil se
concrétise ouvrir son château familial
au public est tout à fait accompagner
par séverine on épouse qui a joué un
rôle d essentielle dans la restauration
de ce château révéler les parquets à
revers il y avait des places sont à
refaire et je dois dire que si on
n'avait pas été 2 je crois que je n'y
serais jamais arrivé et le premier élan
est venu en 71
lorsque nous avons pu demander au musée
grévin de mead les six premiers
personnages pour évoquer les l'histoire
du château
l'histoire de la famille donc ça ça nous
a fait passer de 5000 visiteurs à 42000
visiteurs un château qui le passionnait
henri-françois de breteil pousse son
père à lui donner
le site était destiné à être vendu à des
promoteurs il appelait souvent ce
château un éléphant blanc
il trouvait que c'était vraiment là la
catastrophe que ça avait été le cas pour
lui que tout ce qui se passait avant 14
quand le roi d'angleterre edouard 7
venait c'était de leurs yeux magnifiques
et c deja mais que depuis la guerre
c'était convenant d'un possible ça lui
avait rendu la vie très difficile
henri-françois de breteuil convainc
andré malraux ministre de la culture de
classe et une partie du domaine
à seulement 17 ans le marques qui
souhaitent partager son histoire celle
de breteuil avec les visiteurs dès que
j'arrivais dans dans une bibliothèque
une librairie qu'on me signaler un livre
il y avait même trois lignes sur les
breteil je me précipitais sur le livre
pour voir le talent des matières et voir
ce qu'on disait sur tel ou tel en cède
donc c'est ça que j'ai voulu raconter à
nos visiteurs comment une famille qui
vit ici depuis quatre siècles va
rencontrer l'histoire de de france ou
même l'histoire de l'europe depuis 1969
le château a accueilli environ 5
millions de visiteurs henri-françois de
bretagne est entouré de dix salariés à
plein temps